diese Syrer die seit 20 15 bei uns sind
die unter Merkel Thomas gekommen sind
das ist jetzt auch die Jahre her die
bekommen momentan sehr großzügig die
deutschen Pässe sind aber noch nicht
unbedingt im Arbeitsmarkt integriert und
ich sehe das als politischen Fehler hier
zu schnell dehnen im Pass
hinterherzulaufen ohne zu erwarten dass
die vorher einen Arbeitsplatz haben und
sich integriert haben da sagen die dann
dann geht das mit sehr sehr schwierige
Familie
die Einbürgerung erleichtert sind
natürlich als Vertreter einer
konservativen Partei in einer
schwierigen Situation gerade weil es am
am rechten Rand eine Partei gibt die
gerade wahnsinnige umfragezahlen hat ich
weiß noch nicht ob das hilft die Sprache
dieser Leute zu übernehmen und das ist
dann doch immer wieder der Fall also das
unter verrutscht was und ich finde das
nicht unerheblich wie man über sowas